della maledizione del Verde No
è tornato troppo bello vedere le tane di
ognuno dei Rainbow Friends
e benvenuti il solito Stories oggi
nuovissimo Escape Room con il Rainbow
and Friends invece c'è un'escape Room
tutta a tema Rainbow Friends sarà
bellissimo Mi raccomando raga guardate
il video fino alla fine poi date un voto
a questo Escape Room da 1 a 10 nei
commenti pronti Mettetevi comodi prende
i Popcorn e iniziamo subito pronti
allora vediamo subito come sarà questo
Escape Room e soprattutto se io riuscirò
a prendere il badge prima di Vitale Chi
vincerà tra Team Celeste Oggi è sembro
rosso davanti Ah ah ah
ah siamo proprio nella mappa come nel
gioco Rainbow Friends però è stata un
po' più abbellita forse decorazioni No
no no io no solo tu sai solo macellando
aspetta c'è qualcosa che non quadra qua
non vedo l'ora di scoprire tutti gli
stage di questa mappa è diversa dal
gioco vedete
questa parte nel gioco ufficiale Rainbow
Friends non c'è Aspetta secondo me c'è
però non c'è questo liquido verde e
quella parte dove ci sono le barchette
forse all'inizio non so se ti ricordi
Wow non prendere il palloncino verde
dice che cos'è questo Guarda dove dove
dove l'hai letto Vieni fai dei passi
indietro guarda qui vedi non toccare il
palloncino verde che vuol dire vuol dire
vi ricordate della maledizione del verde
no ah ah è tornato Io nel frattempo
distratta finita possiamo saltare subito
no no non è vero non è vero c'è scritto
che devi evitare i palloncini Verdi
perché mi fa vedere solo il colore verde
non è giusto e io sono saltato su un
palloncino Viola e se lo porta lo stesso
Vabbè comunque per ora mi piace un sacco
queste Escape Room mi piace questa
ambientazione dobbiamo scegliere la
porta giusta che adesso altrimenti si
sfracelli non scegliamo la porta
sbagliata allora che colore mi piace di
più tra verde giallo blu Viola a me
piace di più il viola vediamo quella
giusta lo sai Wow bene dai andiamo
avanti tutti i colori dei personaggi di
Rainbow frantz ovviamente
dove siamo Oh Qui siamo in quel posto Ti
ricordi l'ultima non lo riuscivamo a
trovare quindi era tipo nascosto qua
dietro ti ricordi No come no
a trovare l'ultimo L'ultimo dei Rainbow
Friends non riuscivamo a trovarlo ed era
tipo qua sopra la casa di Orange
quella era un altro gioco per i Rainbow
Friends dove siamo morti prima
ancora oggi se non avete visto gli altri
video gameplay Rainbow Friends andate
poi a vederli così vedrete tutti gli
sfracellamenti che abbiamo fatto però
attenzione quello di morpher davvero
molto simile a questo Beh era la stessa
mappa però non dovevamo scappare dai
Rainbow Friends qua non so se ci saranno
i Rainbow Friends
Eccolo Vabbè io vado non aspetto Vitale
perché devo prendere prima io e Alberto
Smettila di seguirmi Vai tu per i fatti
tuoi eh Capito Non puoi copiarmi Vai via
Ah ah ah ah così imparo Oh no ma adesso
devo ricominciare tutto daccapo tutto
dove andare adesso Ho trovato lo sito No
ciao ciao Vitale
No no devo trovare l'uscita
Ops Ah è uscita Ah ti sei sfracellata
pure tu a quanto pare qua il pavimento
non è lava ma il pavimento è acqua come
se cadere
qualcuno è caduto
via tanto vitello rimarrà nella pentola
a proposito
orecchini del giorno
Uh sono riuscita a vederli bene due
orsacchiotti gommosi celesti che voto
gli date da 1 a 10 scrivetelo nei
commenti
Beh io vado Mi dispiace
tanto non so dove andare Ci sono delle
frecce ingannevoli Ricci ingannevoli Sì
ok
partner
Aspetta forse l'ho trovata L'ho trovata
no ecco Vitale tanto ti sfracellerei
10.000 volte nell'acqua io ancora non ho
capito come fanno a passare così
velocemente Anzi devo aspettare Ok
dobbiamo fare un passaggio per volta
andiamo qua qua dove è vitale Vitale
laggiù
procederà Certo che no sono già dietro
di te
io sono comunque avanti
[Musica]
diversa
vediamo chi si sfracellerà per primo
difficilissimo Uffa Non ti preoccupare
io non ti aspetterò andrò avanti a
prendere il badge prima di te ah ah io
prima ti ho aspettato mi sono fermata a
parlare vero
Escape c'è scritto Nessuna via d'uscita
ma noi la troveremo lo stesso ad avere
l'uscita soprattutto
vediamo speriamo ci sia la sezione
cucina di questa Escape Room così Vitale
si distrarre
Attenzione qui eh che è molto difficile
nostra cellamenti
tu sei il problema
Guardate questo quadro c'è blu con un
personaggio quello Sarà forse il
fondatore creatore dei Rainbow Friends
Può essere perché in effetti Io vorrei
sapere di più sulla storia di Rainbow
Friends se voi sapete tutta la storia
perché voi sapete sempre tutto sapete
tantissime cose dei giochi a cui
giochiamo scrivetecelo nei commenti
perché voglio sapere di più cioè tipo
chi li ha creati da dove vengono come
con unarghi Voglio sapere tutto o no
questo salto è difficilissimo
devi prendere la ricotta a saltare
dritto non so come hai fatto eh senza
scongelarmi uh uh ah ah ah ah
Aspetta ma questo che cos'è È un badge
non ci credo perché tanto ci sono molti
altri
impossibile che li ho presi già il badge
Come hai fatto a saltare questa parte me
lo spieghi te l'ho detto devi prendere
la rincorsa impresa la rincorsa Ma devi
devi saltare dritto nonno yeah
salta dritto
riproviamo lasciate un mi piace per
portarmi fortuna una cosa sabato Vediamo
rullo di tamburi
ma ce l'ho fatta Wow finalmente
non potevo cadere devo cadere vediamo
C'è scritto Non lasciare che blu ti
abbracci potrebbe avere fame Ah ah ah ah
Apre questa porta devi andare nei
Condotti di reazione eh Ecco perché ti
sei bloccata tu eh Eh questo qui che sto
continuando a girare Ehi Ma che ci fai
qui ci sono tre giocatori qua seguiamo
questo giocatore perché sicuramente
Penso di sì sì
vero i vostri giocatori se siete delle
schiappe dei giochi come noi a volte
seguite gli altri giocatori magari sono
più bravi eh ma dove dove siamo finiti
forse possiamo fare legname è un
laboratorio con tutti gli attrezzi Vedi
Non ti far affettare da queste robe uh
uh Aiuto Sono riuscito a passare sono
arrivato Altissimo comunque perché tutto
così gigante siamo noi piccoli oppure se
ne rendo Friends che sono giganteschi
Credo di sì siamo noi che siamo
piccolini non ci credo che ancora non ci
siamo sfracellati
è troppo strano e qui c'è una porta
Ciao Anita Ciao subito
[Musica]
ho capito siamo tornati nella mappa però
ci sono i laser
[Musica]
Dai adesso vediamo come si sfracella
Anita devi passare lì è difficilissimo
tutti e due aspetta Ho capito Eh ho
capito ho capito come fare fai andare
prima a me ok Forse non so come fare dai
vediamo un po' di più in corsa
[Musica]
ho fatto a pezzi
eh Qualcosa mi dice che è una trappola
Io sono passato però sono riuscita a
passare Ah ah ah ah
Aiuto Sono arrivato a pezzi dall'altra
parte Quindi poi mi sono ricomposto Ok
allora proverò anche a prendere la
ricotta eh
Ah ce l'hai fatta aspettate bravissima
Qual è il tuo colore preferito Fra
Questi il mio colore preferito è il
celeste il mio non c'è qua Perché Qual è
il tuo colore preferito di questi il
rosa non c'è quindi scelgo questo questo
Violetto lilla il violetto Ehi tu non ne
approfittare mentre parlo vai avanti
scrivete voi Qual è il vostro colore
preferito Fra Questi di Rainbow Friends
scriveteci nei commenti dai Anita Io ti
aspetto qui Voglio vedere quante volte
ti sposelli mi vedi Sì ma sappi che non
mi sfracello più Non vedo l'ora di
vedere
e aspetta un momento io sono passata
adesso te lo dico vederti sfracellarti
un'altra volta c'è qualche trappola lì
ora la scoprirò vediamo Ho capito Qua ci
sono dei passi quindi dopo un caffè qua
piano piano piano piano piano piano e
poi queste cose blu sicuramente le devo
saltare lì
mi sono pure spaventata Mamma mia
che è sfiorato quello eh ma non ci
riesci sai perché Perché sei una
schiappa
vedremo Chi prenderà il badge Piano
pianissimo
Vabbè mi sono staccato di aspettarti Io
vado avanti Ciao Non lo toccato
l'abbiamo visto tutti siamo nel
nascondiglio di Orange
bellissimo
Guardate troppo bello vedere le tane di
ognuno dei Rainbow Friends Quindi qua
siamo nella tana Appunto una scuola
meravigliosa
voglio esplorarne tu Sì certo come no ah
ah alla fine del video Poi oltre a
scriverci Che voto date da queste Escape
Room da 1 a 10 scriveteci Qual è stata
la vostra tana casa preferita dei
Rainbow Friends al momento quella che mi
piace di più è quella di Orange e la tua
ma è l'unica che abbiamo visto
[Musica]
questo è tornata indietro
devi guardare lì
No basta
è arrivato questa parte Viola oggi 10
volte
no bastava andare dritto di là dai
Guarda la porta è lì ah ah Non ci credo
tutto dritto devi andare
Ok adesso salta su quelli Ecco perché
allora mi sfragio a lavo sempre
a girare sempre lì intorno non trovare
la porta ma ora finalmente siamo Ah
quindi questo è Il nascondiglio di blu
blu
a casa bello Questi quadratini
Arcobaleno
massima concentrazione Non so perché
veramente in questa Escape Room
l'espressione in continuazione È molto
più difficile Oh ce l'ha fatta forse
attenzione
Eccola ce l'ho fatta
Oh porco jookie Guardate sembra un po'
alta da parte dove andiamo ora so che
giochi Avete visto i video non scoppiare
i palloncini c'è scritto la torta
c'erano una torta al cioccolato No
Voglio assaggiare i palloncini
c'era scritto noi scoppiare i palloncini
Eh bravo che si scoppiasse invece si
sfracello nel basta Wow
Cosa hai fatto tutto qua che è successo
e hanno lasciato aperto il rubinetto e
in effetti qua è un po' difficile capire
dove dobbiamo andare è troppo lontano
quel cubo ci sei riuscito Allora ci
riesco anch'io Oh
ciao ciao flagellato No infatti abbiamo
vinto altrimenti non riesco a passare la
labirinto Ok grazie dobbiamo evitare si
procederà Challenge
Bravo attento laser un altro la e ora a
destra o sinistra destra attento Vai
piano altrimenti ti distruggo i laser
e adesso qua a sinistra Certo c'è
qualcosa lì per terra un osso No non è
uno che cos'è Non lo so una lampadina
laser tipo piano piano piano piano piano
Non ti far prendere da questi laser
piano piano piano e dove non ti vedo più
Ah ecco Vai pianissimo
Ehi dove sei Ah eccoti
Brava Hai trovato la via d'uscita L'hai
trovata subito non mi dire che il
cervello
dove sei iscritto
vincitori
non ho capito dobbiamo entrare qua
soprattutto perché non c'hai più la
maglietta che sta succedendo Dove ci ha
portato
siamo in un'altra Hobby ma l'importante
è che abbiamo preso il viaggio di prima
ma io non ti vedo più dove sei Ehi Son
qua davanti Sbrigati
che è successo
Uffa per colpa tua mi sono sfracellata
Oh non mi spinge Comunque ho preso prima
io il peggio Ora proviamo
qua guarda c'è un peggio anche lì c'è
una corona Non ti azzardare no
Ah come ti permette non pensavo che ti
spingessi questo mobile è
giganteschi
bene sappi che questo sarà una gara
sfida all'ultimo sangue non ti aspetterò
e nemmeno tu mi devi aspettare Ok Chi
arriva prima Vince chi arriva per ultimo
non mangia
Veronese il primo proprio per forza
subito mi ha immediatamente
Mi sono fatto a pezzi Mi dispiace ma io
sono più brava in questi in questi Hobby
Parkour rispetto a quello di prima
quindi
riuscirò a prenderti questa maglietta là
dietro ma perché non mi rubano sempre le
magliette guarda
Come mai ve la cavo così bene in queste
Parkour invece nelle azioni che
provocano i laser misura ce l'ho sempre
non capisco
tanto io sono più brava cioè Certo
che bello questo
due volte mi sembra
mi è arrivato no
no
dove Anita Dov'è Anita bello questo
parkour
devo dire che non mi sfracello
dovrei evitare No più veloce più veloce
più veloce presto sbrighiamoci facciamo
più veloce no non mi deve superare
cazzo prima o poi si procede dici
Ah Insomma sfida all'ultimo per turno
non sei capace a giocare Prima che
arrivassi tutta mangiando tutto
buonissimo
non mi aspettare
che ti aspetta
Ma sei dietro di me Ma cosa sono queste
comunque tante cose messe cavolo di
cioccolatini delle palline di cioccolato
e sta arrivando la fame No
non ci credo non sono ancora sprecato
perché questo è un tappeto che si muove
allora che voto date la prima Escape
Room da 1 a 10 e gli do un otto e mezzo
perché mi è piaciuto un sacco con tutte
le ambientazioni tutto Io invece era
troppo breve Secondo me
gli do un nove Allora proprio perché era
troppo breve però mi è piaciuta
tantissimo
E ora vi lasciamo Qua quattro roselline
su cui cliccare per vedere i nostri
altri video cliccate su quella che
preferite e buona visione Ciao